[Music]
foreign
so it's been a pretty interesting uh
series of discussions on differential
equations and dynamical systems in the
last few videos I've shown you how to
integrate differential equations and
systems of differential equations even
if they're non-linear we can integrate
them on a computer using numerical
simulation techniques like runga cuta
schemes or Euler schemes and I mentioned
kind of in passing that there are
certain systems that are that are
chaotic systems that are especially hard
to simulate to integrate accurately
forward in time the kind of amplify
uncertainty and errors maybe even
exponentially in forward time and so
today I'm going to dive in a little bit
more to what I mean by chaos and chaotic
systems I'm going to give you some
definitions and some examples and we're
also going to work out you know kind of
with math some of the implications of
what it means to be chaotic and how we
can interpret these Solutions and also
it'll give us an idea of what we might
be able to do to improve our numerical
algorithms to simulate these kinds of
tricky systems
so this is a
video in Python and Matlab
to simulate the lorentz 1963 problem
this this chaotic system of three
differential equations and what I did
was I took an initial condition and
added a cube of uncertainty this Red
Cube of uncertainty and integrated all
of those trajectories forward in time
and you can see that the trajectories
initially stay together but after a very
short amount of time they start to
stretch and fold and mix onto this
chaotic Lorenz attractor and so this is
kind of pictorial evidence of kind of
the first main point I want to make
which is oftentimes chaos is defined as
a system that has sensitive dependence
on its initial conditions so you can
think of this red blob of uncertainty as
some uncertainty in my initial condition
and very soon as I integrate this this
dynamical system that uncertainty grows
and grows and grows until you know after
some finite amount of time those initial
that grid of particles could be anywhere
on this attractor this is in stark
contrast to a non-chaotic system such as
a pendulum or a mass on a spring
where even if you know the pendulum is
non-linear it has non-linear terms Theta
double dot equals minus sine of theta it
still does not have the sensitive
dependence on initial conditions if I
start with a blob of initial conditions
around some nominal Theta and I let all
of those go they're going to basically
stay together in the same kind of
clockwork and there will be some
predictability in the future based based
on those initial conditions whereas in a
chaotic system you truly have this
sensitive dependence on initial
conditions and so that actually causes
some big issues so for example when we
talked about our numerical integrators
we were trying to find some some
numerical trajectory
let's say you know I have X naught and
then I want to integrate it forward to
get some X1 and integrate that forward
to X2 and so on and so forth
and we developed schemes like the runga
Kata scheme and analyze the error
properties at each time step and so for
example we showed that or at least we
said that the fourth order runga cut a
scheme has error
that is on the order of delta T to the
fifth power where delta T is my time
Step at every single step of the
integrator I have order delta T to the
fifth error now for deterministic
systems what you can do this is this is
what's called the so-called local error
this is um kind of local
uh at each DT at each delta T and for a
deterministic system not like this
chaotic system but more like the
pendulum system you can compute from
this local error what is the global
error across the trajectory because
essentially these errors will just add
up and each time step you're accruing
this order delta T to the Fifth Air
and the length of my trajectory you know
if I make delta T smaller I have more
steps for that to accrue and so the
global error is often uh just this
number divided by delta T so the global
error
would normally be order delta T to the
fourth
true for chaotic systems This Global
error doesn't make sense for chaotic
systems I'm about to show you why so
this is not true
for chaos or for chaotic systems
and the reason is is because at each
little time step when I accrue this very
very small order delta T to the fifth
error so I have you know I take one time
step and my simulated trajectory
deviates from my true trajectory by some
teeny tiny little Epsilon so instead of
going to X1 I go to X1 plus Epsilon
that Epsilon so you know I basically go
to X One Plus Epsilon that's the error
in my numerical scheme it's teeny tiny
but over time because of the sensitive
dependence on initial conditions because
of a chaotic system my this Epsilon is
going to grow exponentially in forward
time so my my trajectory my simulated
trajectory and my true trajectory are
going to diverge even if I'm only
introducing these teeny tiny little
order delta T to the fifth errors at
every time step
so the way that these local errors
compound for chaotic systems is way way
worse than for non-chaotic systems and
so this notion of global error that we
think of for pendula and spring Mass
dampers just doesn't apply to chaotic
systems it's much worse than that you
essentially have something like each of
these little errors these little local
delta T errors at every time step get
magnif to magnified by some exponential
function some e to the Lambda T where
Lambda is a positive number
called the lyapan of exponent liabunov
exponent and that essentially says that
every single time step these little
errors are growing exponentially in time
and so this is going to motivate better
integrators or at least different
integrators for these chaotic systems
oftentimes
so for example if I have a hamiltonian
system or some mechanical system
governed by the Euler LaGrange equations
there are special custom tailor-made
integrators that are designed for those
systems if they're chaotic to to give
you better properties and kind of stay
on the solution manifold more Faithfully
okay so I'll tell you about that a
little bit more in a minute I'll just
mention here that leaponov this is one
of the most controversially spelled
names in all of mathematics I think I've
seen at least three different spellings
of leaponov this is the one I grew up
with so this is the one I'm using that
when you Google the App and on there's
going to be like at least three
different ways to spell this
and so often what we try to do is we try
to use a small enough delta T that our
runga cutter error is actually very very
small to begin with so order delta T to
the fifth we want that to be as close to
machine precision as possible you know
10 to the minus 12 10 to the minus 16.
but even if this Epsilon is 10 to the
minus 16 for a positive Lambda it
doesn't take very long for this error to
grow to order one to a big significant
error in our in our simulation
and last thing I'll point out before I
give you some examples is in this
chaotic lorentz system because the
trajectory is kind of bound to this
white attractor this is the so-called
strange attractor or the lorentz
butterfly attractor that that Epsilon
grows initially exponentially but then
eventually uh it the trajectory is still
stuck adhering onto this
um this strange attractor and so I can
actually get away with using something
like rk4 if all I care about is the
rough shape of this attractor or the
rough statistics of this tractor maybe I
don't care if this is the exact uh
perfect trajectory that that initial
condition would take this is a
representative trajectory because it's
going to you know do the representative
thing uh on this Lorent system if I
wanted a you know very quantitatively
accurate trajectory that followed the
exact true Dynamics I might need to use
something more fancy than a runga cutter
scheme so we'll come back to this in a
minute and we'll talk more about these
kind of numerical considerations
the other examples I like to think about
so this is kind of one of our canonical
simplest examples it's a three-state ode
that happens to be chaotic
the solar system is another great
example so chaos was actually discovered
or at least kind of codified
mathematically by Honore Point array in
the early 1900s I think it might have
been 1906 right around the time Einstein
was making his great discoveries Point
array was kind of solidifying this
theory of chaotic dynamical systems and
actually a lot of the dynamical systems
and differential equations that we use
even to this day come from come from
point array about a century ago and so
the idea is that there are chaotic
trajectories in the solar system and
it's pretty easy to understand this if
you think about
um I don't know it's a little hard to
see but let's pretend that that's Earth
and let's pretend that the Moon is
somewhere over here but between the
Earth and the moon there is this equal
gravity point this saddle point it's
literally a fixed point of that
dynamical system where and it has saddle
eigenvalues so you know it has one
positive real and one negative real
eigenvalue
and what that means is if I am at this
equal gravity point between the Earth
and the moon and I'm perfectly on that
point then I'll stay at that equal
spacing you know that equal gravity
distance between the Earth and the moon
but if I perturb myself a teeny tiny bit
towards the moon I'll accelerate towards
the moon and if I perturb myself a teeny
tiny bit towards the Earth I'll
accelerate towards the Earth and so you
can see that at least locally to that
fixed point I get this exponential
splitting of my trajectories because of
that saddle point and so that is one of
the Hallmark features in chaos is that
usually there is some kind of a saddle
point that's mediating uh mediating the
stretching and kind of exponential
growth of trajectories in that system
actually if I go back to this uh Lorenz
system you'll see that this bundle of
trajectories actually stays pretty close
together until it gets close to this
Saddle Point here so it's still on the
same lobe but now they're going to pull
down and get close to the saddle point
and that's what causes them to really
stretch in this exponential positively
happening exponent way
and I'll mention that this this
technically these trajectories don't
split
monitor the the separation between two
neighboring trajectories with this
sensitive dependence on initial
Condition it's not monotonic exponential
growth it's kind of on average
exponential growth Sometimes they come
closer together before they move apart
and it's usually driven by how close
they get to these saddle points so
saddle points are really essential in
this kind of picture of chaos again this
is a whole class that I I hope to offer
at some point in the future you know
many many uh kind of lectures and hours
of content here I'm just giving you the
very high level especially as it relates
to how do you numerically simulate
ordinary differential equations
and so in the solar system um and I want
to point out like having a saddle
doesn't mean you are guaranteed to be
chaotic that just means you locally will
have trajectories separate
um you know a pendulum if I look at the
pendulum up condition that also has a
saddle point that you know trajectories
will kind of diverge locally in time but
in a very predictable way
but you know if I have enough Saddles
and I have a high enough dimensional
system like this interplanetary uh you
know like the solar system Network
oftentimes that gives rise to really
chaotic trajectories
and it turns out in this case you can
actually harness these chaotic
trajectories and harness this
exponential growth for very efficient
transport to very different regions of
the solar system that's kind of depicted
here in this artist's representation is
that if I can get near one of these
points where I get this kind of very
large sensitivity in this large
spreading then with a small amount of
fuel burn a little Delta V of my rocket
ship I can go from you know I can jump
from this tube to this tube and go to
completely different places in the solar
system for for small amounts of energy
now this Epsilon would be like a small
amount of energy allows me to to get
this large amplification so chaos is not
always a bad thing but it is hard to
predict and it's hard to simulate and
it's hard to estimate there are in fact
special integrators used to to integrate
this dynamical system
um you know from our various Global
space agencies that you know our super
computer simulations of what the solar
system and all of its objects will look
like
um you know at some time in the future
and these are very very uh tricky
simulations because of the chaotic
nature of the system
to give in my class a sensitive
dependence on initial condition is the
double pendulum so the double pendulum
is probably the simplest mechanical
system that exhibits chaos and and by
double pendulum I literally mean
um
it's one pendulum with another pendulum
attached to it so there's two thetas
there's Theta one and Theta two and this
double pendulum you can picture kind of
almost how this thing would would swing
and maybe do some pretty crazy things so
what I did was I actually built this was
for my first class ever
um teaching here at University of
Washington I built an apparatus where I
have two double pendulum right next to
each other so it's called the tandem
double pendulum I got this idea from the
controls and dynamical systems library
at Caltech where I believe Jerry Marsden
had someone gifted a tandem double
pendulum so it's two double pendula
right next to each other
and you can start them at the same
initial condition and when you let them
go they their trajectories do agree for
a little while and then at some point
they diverge because of this x this
sensitive dependence on initial
condition so I built one of those for my
class and that's what we're visualizing
here I start them at the same initial
condition and then let go they're
actually agreeing pretty well
until they don't and now they've
diverged into totally different
solutions small changes in the initial
condition small changes in the system
parameters the um friction the length of
the pendula will eventually cause these
trajectories to to diverge in this kind
of exponential lyopanet exponent way
which is really cool and you can try
this thing from different initial
conditions you know maybe at some point
I'll take a video outside and actually I
tried to bring it in here but the
lighting is just not good enough for for
these that kind of blend in
um and we can try different initial
conditions so for example if I start
with my my tandem double pendulum where
they're both in the down down position
and I perturb them a small amount they
actually that is not chaotic they
basically will act like little pendulum
clocks and they'll almost perfectly
track each other forever until they die
out to zero
um and I actually chose this initial
condition where you know one of them was
at this kind of 90 degree angle because
that is an initial condition that has
enough energy that you kind of excite
the chaos in the system and so that's
another key principle here is that a lot
of times for mechanical systems for the
the planetary Dynamics there is a
certain energy level above which uh
these chaotic Dynamics are really
excited and activated and again it has
to do with the saddle points in the
system
so in this uh this double pendulum
system the pendulum uh if I if I
linearize the Dynamics we know how to
linearize the Dynamics the down down
um configuration just the kind of really
easy down down configuration with you
know small perturbations that is
actually a linear center it's got a plus
or minus I Omega plus or minus I Omega
eigenvalues and so it's neutrally stable
it's not chaotic but when I increase the
energy and so now I have the first
pendulum arm down and the second
pendulum arm up so kind of the down up
configuration if I linearize this system
you should do this yourself at home if
you linearize these Dynamics you'll find
out that it has a saddle Direction in
that fixed Point there's one set of plus
minus real eigenvalues and this saddle
point is where the chaos comes from so
if I start with energy Above This saddle
point I'll get chaotic Solutions like
this so that's why I start from that
initial condition because this is where
you'll see that sensitive dependence on
initial conditions is for energies Above
This saddle point we actually just wrote
a couple of cool papers showing that the
Dynamics of this pendulum are almost
mathematically identical to the Dynamics
of the the three body problem that we've
been studying you know for over 100
years in in planetary Dynamics making
this double pendulum kind of a cool
tabletop experiment to start
understanding chaotic transport in the
solar system and again in both of those
systems we need good numerical
integrators and we need to understand
how our error grows through these these
chaotic systems through this sensitive
dependence on initial conditions
again that's the key Point here is
sensitive dependence on initial
conditions you're going to hear that
over and over again there are other
things people use to describe chaos kind
of Hallmark features but that's really
the one that I always keep coming back
to is
um that you know a small change in
initial conditions often gets Amplified
kind of exponentially at least for a
while in these chaotic systems
good
uh and you can actually you know since I
built this about 10 years ago we've
actually built a few much better
experimental rigs in the lab so you can
control a chaotic system so we've pumped
in a lot of energy so it's well above
the chaotic threshold but with feedback
control and with a good enough
integration scheme a good enough kind of
model predictive controller we can
actually swing this pendulum up and
stabilize a condition that's normally
unstable and definitely with enough
energy that you would classify if I let
the system go it would have a chaotic
Dynamic okay this is actually the the
third generation double pendulum that we
built in my lab I think we're on to the
fourth generation now which is even kind
of fancier and nicer than this where you
can do all kinds of cool acrobatic
control again using the fact leveraging
this chaotic Dynamics to put in only a
small amount of energy at the right time
and using kind of the internal chaotic
Dynamics to to get the system to behave
the way you want it to
so really cool stuff again just just
kind of illustrating that you can in
fact control these systems uh sometimes
if you're lucky okay
I want to tell you about
um so we've talked about how chaotic
systems involve this exponential growth
of small perturbations mathematically
maybe I want to show you actually
mathematically how you would write this
down because I think this is pretty
useful so let's say you have your
differential equation uh x dot equals f
of x now technically this could vary in
time as well this could be f of x comma
T no big deal nothing's going to change
and what I write it's just a little more
complicated
and often what we will say is that um
the numerical solution X at some future
time T is equal to X naught exit time 0.
plus an integral from times 0 to time T
of the Dynamics F of and now X is is my
trajectory X is my trajectory which is a
function of time and so you evaluate F
at each of these intermediate times from
0 to T along a trajectory and you
integrate this up using a dummy variable
Tau now you can kind of carefully
convince yourself you know that this is
in fact how how you would integrate the
system mathematically this is kind of an
idealization of what we would do in
these these rangakatta schemes or
Euler schemes this is like a
mathematical expression that if you
perfectly did this integral and you
perfectly integrated up all of these
contributions of f to x dot and kept
adding those up along along the
trajectory and you kept updating f as X
changed as X moves along that trajectory
then this will step your your system
forward in time and oftentimes I call
this the the flow map operator sometimes
I call this this big flow map from 0 to
T of some X naught and it steps me
forward from t 0 to T to time T okay
this is a mathematical object
and what we'll find is that for chaotic
systems so this is actually like the one
of the first papers I ever wrote In fact
the first paper I ever wrote when I was
a grad student was about analyzing the
properties of this flow map when you add
a teeny perturbation when you add a
little Epsilon to your X so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say what if
I had instead of X naught I had X naught
plus an Epsilon so if I have Phi
you know my flow map I'm integrating uh
from X naught but what if I have X
naught plus an Epsilon plus a teeny tiny
little Epsilon of perturbation and this
Epsilon could be from a numerical
artifact it could be 10 to the minus 16
round off error in how I stored this it
could be an order delta T to the fifth
error for my runga cut a scheme whatever
it is I want to know how that error
propagates through this flow map
and so you can tailor expand this
because this Epsilon is small so we can
tailor expand around this is a function
it's a it's a smooth function typically
and so I can tailor expand and this is
going to equal the flow map that I want
this V 0 t of X naught
plus the Jacobian of this flow map plus
d uh let's say d Phi DX
yeah zero to T evaluated at X naught
times my Epsilon
plus I could write out more and more
terms plus higher order terms in epsilon
plus order let's say epsilon squared and
higher terms okay and so essentially
this is the true flow map this is the
true trajectory X at time T this is what
I actually want and this is my leading
error term so this is my kind of leading
error term
leading error
and this is actually how we compute this
Lambda at least approximately for for
finite time trajectories for finite time
t uh kind of the leading eigenvalue of
well the leading singular value of this
Matrix of derivatives evaluated at X
naught is going to give me an estimate
of my my lyapana of exponent Lambda
because essentially what this does is
this says this Jacobian this is a matrix
when I evaluate this set of partial
derivatives with respect to X naught
this is a matrix and I can compute this
numerically using things like the finite
timely opponent of exponent so I have a
whole video on that you can check out of
how to actually compute this thing and
approximate it from trajectory data but
the long story short is that
this is a matrix when I evaluated at X
naught and it tells me that that Matrix
has you know eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and singular values and
singular vectors there are directions
that that Matrix makes bigger and
there's directions that that Matrix
makes smaller and so if my error is
aligned with one of the bad directions
of this this amplifying Matrix then my
error is going to get Amplified and so
what we find is that this Matrix has
oftentimes for chaotic systems this
Matrix will have large singular values
meaning there are directions that if
error is in that direction those will
get Amplified exponentially and so what
you do mathematically I'll just write
this down in case you're curious you
don't have to understand all the steps
there's a whole video and a whole papers
about this is that you could basically
pick the max
singular value of this dvdx
and that is going to equal essentially
approximately this e to the Lambda T so
you could approximately your lyapanov
exponent Lambda by taking the logarithm
of this the maximum singular value and
dividing by the integration time T so
that gives you a way of estimating how
this error propagates through your
system and this kind of synthesizes a
lot of things we thought about in this
series on differential equations so this
is the perfect trajectory integration
scheme if I had infinitesimal truly DT
delta T is like truly calculus
infinitesimal DTS this would be exact
and true this would give me the
trajectory at any point in time
but we know that we're chopping up our
trajectory into finite Delta T's that
accrue some error some Epsilon error and
so if I assume that at each time step I
introduce this error Epsilon maybe it's
even 10 to the minus 16. maybe I have an
amazing integrator and it's as good as
my computer can represent numbers but
I'm still going to have some
representation error 10 to the minus 16
at the you know best case here I can
tailor expand that out and I get these
interesting terms for my Taylor series
where I can isolate that this is the
leading error term and the point I'm
trying to make is that for chaotic
systems this leading error term
amplifies like e to the Lambda T okay
which is a big deal that's really bad
that means that even my 10 to the minus
16 error is going to amplify and stretch
and grow
and so there's ways you can control that
and there's ways you can understand how
big that Lambda is numerically using
these finite Timely app on all exponents
by actually Computing the singular value
decomposition of this or if you like the
eigenvalue decomposition of this times
its transpose
um the koshy green stress stress tensor
um so I think that that's pretty
interesting uh something else I think I
want to to tell you about is if I take a
mechanical system like this double
pendulum so in fact exactly like this
double pendulum let's assume that there
is no friction on these bearings so
we're going to make an idealized you
know perfect
hamiltonian system or lagrangian system
of no dissipation we know that the
energy should be conserved in this
system okay so if I literally plot you
know energy
versus time there should be a constant
line for any trajectory that I integrate
starting from X naught to some x t that
energy should be constant
now this is actually a really good
exercise you should write down the
double pendulum equations of motion you
can do this from the Euler LaGrange
equations or from the hamiltonian
equations pretty pretty easy to do it's
a little messy you're going to get all
the Sines and cosines right but it's not
so hard
and you should write down an rk4
integrator for that problem and simulate
that trajectory forward in time and
compute the energy at each time step and
what you'll find
is that the energy of the rk4
is going to be a mess it's going to
diverge from this constant maybe it'll
go to negative Infinity maybe it'll go
to positive Infinity but it's not going
to be a constant it's far from a
constant when you integrate these
mechanical systems basic basic
fundamental conservation laws like
conservation of energy are being
violated and like truly violated here
um I feel violated when I integrate A
system that should be conservative with
an RK scheme and you should too
and so there are better numerical
algorithms for integrating these kinds
of chaotic systems if there's that
additional structure if we know that our
system is hamiltonian so for hamiltonian
systems
uh hamiltonian there are integrators
called simplexic integrators simplexic
and they essentially let's say
symplectic integrators there's some
really good algorithms out there for
some plectic integrators where
essentially we know that hamiltonian
systems generally have this kind of
um
skew symmetric structure between
positions and momentum so that you have
something something some some skew
symmetric structure like this in your
equations and what simplectic
integrators do is that they build the
numerical updating scheme so that every
time step this is this structure is
exactly preserved so if you like all of
these errors even when they accrue they
are still being kind of projected back
onto a manifold where the basic physics
the basic energy conservation
is being satisfied so those algorithms
like a simplectic maybe I'll make this
in green something like simplectic
you know even when the integrator tries
to you know pull it off of this energy
surface it's kind of constantly
correcting it and staying very very
close to that energy surface so these
are
Reef you want to integrate you know a
spaceship through the solar system or if
you want to know how a space rock is
going to be hurtling through the solar
system you better be using a smart
integrator or else you're going to get
garbage you're not going to know if it's
going to hit Earth in 50 years or not
because your simulator is completely off
base okay just like there are simplectic
integrators there are also and that
preserves hamiltonian structure
structure if you have something that is
you know if you want to start from the
lagrangian
um which these are kind of equivalent
um you know ways of representing
mechanical systems the Euler LaGrange
equations if you want to discreetly in a
computer integrator satisfy the
lagrangian the Euler LaGrange equations
these are called variational integrators
variational
and I might you know I spent a lot of
time developing variational and
simplexic integrators in research and
you know back
um you know a decade ago maybe I'll have
a whole video on variational and
simplexic integrators because they're so
important
for integrating hard chaotic systems
where you really need to know uh good
trajectories good answers for a specific
initial condition again in that lorentz
case I was showing you I just wanted to
know kind of the statistics of how
things happened and so it didn't really
matter I wasn't I didn't care about that
single trajectory and where it went as
much as the statistics but if I'm
following an asteroid or you know a
space Rock in the solar system I really
want to know that specific trajectory
where it's going to be I need these
better variational and simplexic
integrators
now it turns out kind of a fun
happenstance that a an
rk78 integrator this is sometimes called
the rkf the runga cut of felberg seven
eight
rkf78 it turns out that our
kf78 is nearly symplectic for lots of
problems and so it's actually an amazing
integrator it has kind of all of the
properties of an RK integrator very
small single step error so very accurate
and single steps and it approximately is
simplectic on lots of problems I
couldn't tell you why to be honest this
is something I've heard people say and
I've observed it myself that when you
simulate these chaotic systems this
tends to work much much better than this
because of some structural property here
so that's interesting too
um
good yeah so this is really important
um
and and you you sometimes need these
these better uh integrators you know
again for for things like control
applications I can't have my energy
blowing up in my model prediction uh for
really tricky prediction problems I
can't have my my error blowing up for
these systems
okay good
that I think are really cool so I'm
going to bring up some more videos I'm
going to erase this really quickly and
then bring up those videos and then I'll
conclude
foreign and I'll also point out I got
this interesting advice once when I was
an undergraduate that you know a human
life is also chaotic it feels very
chaotic sometimes sometimes it feels
more
deterministic sometimes it feels fully
chaotic
um but you know the choices you make can
often have these large kind of Divergent
effects right so this is a it's an
interesting it's an interesting meta
perspective that you know small changes
to what you do can add up to large
changes over time
uh and so you know understanding having
some model predictive control
understanding where you think you're
going and where you want to go and
figuring out you know am I at one of
these critical points where things could
go totally differently and you know if
in those cases I'm going to slow down
I'm going to decrease my delta T I'm
going to think harder uh about you know
about what decisions decisions I'm
making so anyway kind of interesting I
thought that was uh that was fun this
was like a cocktail party when I was an
undergrad and and uh Jerry Marsden told
me about you know like the butterfly
effect and how
decisions you know you make now can make
a big difference later on and he was
absolutely right okay so some other cool
examples
fluid flows are often
chaotic and so specifically turbulence
when someone talks about turbulence or a
turbulent fluid flow often we model that
turbulence as a chaotic dynamical system
so there is a deep deep relationship for
you know many decades researchers in
turbulence have studied chaotic
dynamical systems and researchers in
chaos have used turbulence to motivate
what they're doing I feel like I'm
getting
a little bit trapped here and so this is
a cool example of a thermal convection
you have a hot plate on the bottom and a
cold plate on top and you get this kind
of thermal convection this is actually
exactly what lorentz was uh was studying
in this Lorenz 1963 model was the
chaotic convection in the Earth's
atmosphere so you know the Noonday Sun
let's say you wake up in the morning the
Sun starts beating down on the planes it
heats up the planes and it creates these
large thermal convection patterns you
often get big thunderstorms and
supercell clouds and things like that
and this system can be at least
approximated by this chaotic
differential equation on the right
and so this um you know was observed
that similar conditions from day to day
at you know starting conditions can
often lead to very very different cloud
formation and weather formation and
precipitation and all kinds of things
that are captured in this model so this
uncertainty and sensitivity of chaotic
convection was captured in this 1963
Lorenz model
I always add Fetter and Hamilton
um
Linda Fetter and Margaret Hamilton when
I put this author list down because they
were the grad students who actually ran
the simulations that Lorenzo used to
build these models by modern
collaboration standards they would
almost certainly be co-authors on that
work and I don't think we should forget
their contribution to this extremely
important chaotic dynamical system that
we all use
um and more generally in fluid dynamics
you can kind of picture how this this
chaos arises if you think about
sensitive dependence on initial
conditions this is super cool work
um by the kth group I love this video
I've used this video before and I'm a
huge fan of their their simulations and
their work where they simulate this
super super high fidelity numerical
simulation of the turbulence over over
wings and things like that
and so the fluid flow itself is chaotic
if I perturbed one of these vortices by
even a little bit the flow the exact
configuration would change quite rapidly
and give you a totally different
distribution so it would give you the
same distribution of vortices but a
different instance a different
realization this Vortex might be over
here and this one might be over here and
things like that so small changes
in the flow field itself will cause the
flow field to change over time things
get Amplified as it goes through this
flow and down here small changes up here
will have big changes down here that's
one one interpretation of chaos another
one that I like is imagine you're a
little particle this is kind of fun or a
little particle and we're you know in
this flow if I start one Epsilon to the
left or one Epsilon to the right I'm
going to get pulled into a whole
different network of vortices and my
path is going to be completely different
even with a teeny tiny Epsilon
perturbation to my initial condition so
a lot of Chaos in this system as well
and this is where I want to point out
you know when I was kind of growing up
in dynamical systems I was
deep into this three-body problem Solar
System Dynamics planetary Dynamics fluid
dynamics where chaos is just a part of
our life it's everywhere and I kind of
thought to myself well how could you
possibly have a high dimensional
dynamical system with the x dot equals f
of x that wasn't chaotic and I met some
friends in grad school who had high
dimensional dynamical systems that were
in fact very much non-chaotic and they
actually kind of self-organized and
self-ordered if you think about it your
body is an incredibly High dimensional
incredibly High dimensional dynamical
system and all there although there are
aspects of chaos locally it's extremely
well regulated and ordered and kind of
these emergent patterns reinforce and
and persist right like your metabolic
regulation kind of says that at least
those variables are not diverging you
can you can eat a Snickers bar or I can
skip lunch and typically you know those
perturbations don't cause my system to
go completely chaotic sometimes they can
certainly but you have a lot of kind of
stability and determinism built into
this very high dimensional system so
clearly chaos is not a universal
property of all dynamical systems so
even in really really complicated fluid
flows
oftentimes you get these coherent
structures these patterns that keep
coming up and keep forming over and over
again even in very turbulent
flows that this is locally chaotic but
there are these large-scale emergent
synchronizations and patterns
um you know this you can see I think
this is a great example this um flow
this is an atmospheric flow past
Guadalupe Island where again this is a
chaotic system we know that weather is
chaotic fundamentally and fluid Flows In
in general are also but you still get
the emergence of these large-scale
structures and so one of the my favorite
videos is this uh metronome
synchronization video so I've been
playing this for my class for the last
10 years I love this video where you
basically have
this initial condition so someone comes
in and they start all these these uh
metronomes these little pendulum at
different initial conditions
and um so that's totally disorganized
and I'm going to turn up my volume here
because I kind of actually want you to
hear
all the clicking
they're all over the place
and you'll notice that they're on this
kind of table that is Loosely able to
vibrate so sometimes the example I've
seen you can build one of these at home
you take two cans of you know Soda Coke
and you put a little plank on top of it
and then you put your little metronomes
on top of here and the weak Epsilon
coupling between these uh because this
this can can uh the plank can roll on
top of this uh these cylinders will
eventually cause these to synchronize
and so uh what you're and this is a
common phenomena in lots of high
dimensional systems that are weakly
coupled
let me keep watching this
so at some point there's going to be a
phase change where they start to
synchronize
[Music]
it's almost happened you can almost see
now like half of them have started to
synchronize and some of them are out of
phase but they're they're definitely
starting to synchronize almost
and it's almost happened now
and the more they synchronize the more
they synchronize so this table you can
actually see the table wobbling now now
it's giving a very strong force in
keeping them all synchronized
and this guy over here this one's my
hero that one's not that one's gonna
take the longest to synchronize
that one uh over there is going to take
the longest to synchronize so it doesn't
you know some of these will will take a
little while but you can see that this
emergent Behavior Uh does exist in these
systems and sometimes all it takes is a
little Epsilon coupling so that you get
this feedback
um to kind of bring them into synchrony
so you know we've known for a long time
uh when soldiers cross a bridge in
formation they're supposed to break uh
you know break their their marching
cadence or else they could bring the
bridge down this is this has been known
for a long time you're supposed to break
step when you cross bridges in large
groups the Millennium bridge in London
that really cool Bridge walking bridge
with the cool cables that had a weak
coupling so that when people walked
across it when one person stepped and it
caused the bridge to move a little bit
to one side everyone else brace
themselves out of phase and caused
another force and those eventually cause
everyone to synchronize just like this
and that almost broke the bridge down
everyone had to like drop on all fours
and crawl off because of this kind of
emergent synchronization so I guess the
point I'm trying to make here is that
High dimensional dynamical systems uh
can be chaotic they can be deterministic
they can synchronize they can
desynchronize there's a lot of super
duper Rich phenomena in these systems
that you can observe and predict and
estimate and control but you know really
understanding how the numerics works and
how you would simulate these in a
computer how small perturbations can
grow exponentially you know those are
all really really important this is a
rich field it's one of the most
interesting fields in all of mathematics
because it ties together you know
differential equations and linear
algebra and numerics and computation and
physics and it it explains and allows us
to describe the world that we observe
around us which changes in time and
evolves according to rules and has
instabilities and synchronizations and
all of it and it's super fascinating I'm
glad you have been with me on this
series and I hope I hope that there are
more and that you get you know
interested in in following in some of
these these leads and threads thank you
all so much
[Music]